the 10 highest paid drivers in Formula 1
collected an estimated $258 million in
2023 before taxes and two big stars
account for almost half of that total
unlike forbes' earning list for say
soccer or the NBA the Formula 1 ranking
excludes income from business Endeavors
such as endorsements focusing solely on
the sports salaries and bonuses because
drivers are generally required to make
appearances on behalf of their team and
the team's partners most of them spend
little effort seeking out personal
sponsorships still despite the lack of
endorsement deals Formula 1 drivers are
Bonafide Global stars and increasingly
relevant in the US where the Netflix
docu series drive to survive has
attracted a passionate fan base here are
the top five highest paid Formula 1
drivers at number five is Charles lir a
report over the summer claimed that lir
fifth on the grid this season after a
second place finish in 2022 had agreed
to a record-breaking contract extension
with Ferrari that turned out to be false
but he recently affirmed that he hopes
to stay with the Prancing horse beyond
the next season at number four is Sergio
Perez Perez won two of The Season's
first four races combining with teammate
Max foren to give Red Bull Racing 21
Grand Prix victories in 22 races and
helping him finish second in the driver
standings at number three is Fernando
Alonzo in his first season with Aston
Martin the hugely popular Alonzo
finished fourth in the driver standings
the 42-year-old Spaniard was the last
driver not named beropen or Hamilton to
lead the Formula 1 earnings race making
an estimated $30 million on forbes' 2013
list of the world's highest paid
athletes at number two is Lewis Hamilton
one of only two drivers in F1 history to
have won seven championships alongside
the legendary Michael Schumacher
Hamilton rebounded from 2022 is sixth
place finish to NAB third this season
Hamilton reached the podium at just six
races in 2023 his fewest in his season
since 2013 but the 38-year-old British
Superstar isn't going anywhere ending
months of speculation by signing a
multi-year contract extension with
Mercedes in August and at number one is
Max veren Red Bull racings Max veren
just completed the most dominant season
in Formula 1 history claiming a record
19 race victories and sewing up the
driver's title all the way back on
October 7th
no surprise then that he's the series
Financial Champion as well with an
estimated $70 million in salary and
bonus this year to lead all Formula 1
drivers and Rabin is due for a raise
next season as his 5-year contract
extension with Red Bull
begins